it's absolutely lovely to see you again
here it collective area how are you
enjoying it so far I'm very much very
much it's been a good day it's been nice
and steady all morning people have been
lovely
and as usual they've come from far and
wide which is great to see so it's been
very pleasant it's been a dramatic
season three for you and for everyone
first of all what was your reaction to
the red wedding when you saw it well you
see I knew because I'd read the books so
I wasn't kind of like you know gutted or
gobsmacked really I knew it was coming
it's still very shocking because you
know especially the stark family there's
something about the stark family you've
identified with them from the beginning
you've believed that he's the bee's
knees and you know he's the nobleman and
lo and behold he kills them off in book
one so then you assume well surely the
rest of the family was somehow you know
carry on and and and be impressive so
when they get wiped out like that it's
quite you know shocking really I kind of
feel and hope I mean I don't know
because none of us knows I kind of feel
in hope that the Starks in some form or
another have a positive end to this
whole saga but who knows at this stage
no one's safe on there anything can
happen I mean you've had a traumatic
season as well on Game of Thrones he
felt about what's happened with
Barristan this this season well now of
course I gotta be careful here we're
talking about season 3 yes so I gotta be
careful about that
well it's great for us of all at least
back
I mean again I I admit that because I
read the book so I was delighted about
that it's great to be back in a series
where so many people don't come back you
know but what his future what
everybody's future will be of course is
yet to be known and we've had a dramatic
time cutting us way through esos as I
think that country is called and who
knows you know how long before we get
our act together and manage to get back
to Westeros but you know we're currently
we're making our way through bear sauce
and we'll see where we end up if you
could give barrister and some advice of
how he should act in future or what he
should keep doing or not do the future
what would you say to him any Barisan
should probably follow his current
agenda which is to be loyal support of
discreet and you know the honorable man
because in a sense I mean he is cut off
that path he is the honorable man and I
trust will remain so you know where he
is at the moment with Danny he's of
course also with um Jorah Mormont what
do you think he makes them exactly
because I feel like there's something
there there's a bit of sort of a little
bit of tension maybe there's the
potential for that certainly because
Barristan obviously knows Joris history
and I guess in some ways he would not
approve of Jorah and in some ways Jorah
might certainly be wary of or mistrust
Barristan they seem to be able to get
along and you know in the presence of
Danny and I see no reason why they
shouldn't but there's possibly enough
kind of like under the surface that who
knows at some point it may come through
it come to the fore but we'll have to
wait and see no one's safe and those
deaths on the red wedding are incredible
but I mean so many amazing exits on Game
of Thrones have a look if you have to
have a dramatic exit stage death how
would you like to go out I'm trying to
work out what my exit will be I mean I
think I've got well first of all I've
already had an exit which was fairly
dramatic but what my next exit will be I
don't know I could die in battle because
after all he is a fighting man and that
would seem appropriate I might make it
through to even older age or who knows I
might make it through to being what I
once was being again what I once was
which is commander of the Queen's Guard
but back in Westeros who knows these
things are to be discovered and none of
us knows because George hasn't even
written it yet so none of us knows but
fingers crossed he where he will carry
on for a while I guess you know if a
fighting man's gonna go he should go
fight him you know I mean it has been a
little sneak peak that George has given
audiences to the next book which he's
written a certain amount of and if he
realizes
bearson's got two points of view
chapters in that what do you what do you
think about that well I'm delighted by
that obviously you know and in a sense
it's kind of not surprising because that
character is it's growing in influence
you know what I mean and I mean
traditionally it's kind of interesting
if you look back if you look back to
Series one although he was part of the
consult you never saw him in any of
Marathi ins council meetings because he
was he's essentially you know he's ahe's
a soldiering man he's interested in
being out in the open right in the area
not really interested in sort of like
sitting around in council meetings that
was his world but as time goes on that
he is I think partly because he's now a
tiny part because she's young in years
but not nesting in sense he may feel
that he has to play more of a counselor
role and and so I think it's kind of not
surprising that perhaps he starts to
have that kind of standing if you like
in her world but where it will lead and
how long it will continue like that who
knows we talked a little bit about
deaths on the show you said how you'd
like to go in battle but what do you
think have been the best deaths that
they've had on the show so far the most
mind-bogglingly amazing ones oh I don't
really know if I can answer that
say yes race I mean you can't it's very
hard to go beyond the red wedding at the
moment to be honest you know I mean the
battle scenes in and Blackwater were
fantastic but I guess because the red
wedding was full of so many people with
whom you had identified so strongly
personally and and full of characters
from the family which is probably the
family that in my head I think is like
you know one of the if you like the
repositories of Honor that was tough you
know so seeing those people go I think
that's still gotta be the toughest you
know if you could put anybody on the
throne who would you like to see on the
Iron Throne at the end of the day
obviously we don't know who it's gonna
be because doesn't finish the well I
mean and from the point of view of my
character it has to be Daenerys cuz
that's what I've know ways and certainly
it would seem at this stage that is
shaping that way I have a suspicion
though that Jon Snow you know there's a
different story there Jon Snow is not
who he appears to be and and I think we
learned something interesting about Jon
Snow and where exactly that places
things and the balance I don't know
and what George has up his sleeve
because of that I don't know but there's
definitely there's definitely a story
there somewhere definitely a story of
many
questions as well and if you could see
anything happen with the Dragons here
we've had some quite interesting action
with last season what would you like to
see happen with the Dragons in future
I'm kind of wondering how big they're
gonna get you know and how we're
actually gonna fill them with them when
they get that big
I mean how they got to be jumbo jet size
before they're done and are we going to
be doing serious CGI with them I don't
know also I guess the other big question
is are they going to be indefinably as
biddable as they currently are you know
because as they get bigger one presumes
they will get more independent and who
knows where that will lead one thing you
can be sure of as long as she possibly
can
she'll hang on to them because basically
that's that's our strengths if you like
is that we are fortunate enough to have
dragons our problem is also that we
happen to have dragons you know because
they may bring they may bring issues as
time goes on we will have to wait and
see on that one too
you